ladies and gentlemen please welcome ben
platt
hi drew oh ben
i'm so happy to see you i'm so happy to
see you too
and the last time i saw you um i believe
we have a picture here
of uh the very first time i met you was
after
a performance of dear evan hansen and
we're both a puppy we're both so puffy
and red
i've never seen a performance like that
in my life
i don't know how you summoned that every
day
and now it's a it's gonna be a film
it is it is it's very wild we just made
it uh this past fall
um and it was my first experience
creating something on stage and then
getting the opportunity to
immortalize it on film and like you said
alongside
monster talents like julianne moore and
amy adams and caitlin deaver amandla
stenberg
you know nick o'donnie it's it was
really really special and bizarre
experience for sure
that dear evan hansen was such a
phenomenon
in its production design in its
storytelling in its acting and
performances but it's a whole 360 about
the way we handle life and what comes
at us and what we are born with and how
families
and how we survive school it is a
survival guide in the most poetic
profound way and i'm so glad that it's
coming to theaters because
this is not a movie this is a hand guide
to life
and it's it's due to you and your
performance at the helm of it truly
thank you so much yeah i think it's
going to be a really moving experience
for
a lot of different ages of people for
young people for parents
it's a lot about uh miscommunication and
misconnection
and i think particularly after this year
of like this covid nightmare of
everybody being so isolated i think
it's going to be particularly poignant
uh in terms of
everybody's inability and ability to
reach out and the ways in which we
struggle to do that
and the magic that can happen when you
do connect with someone and finally feel
seen
and can overcome you know whatever
obstacles you're up against for me
personally
much like evan it's it's anxiety and and
worry and
um to be able to move past those things
and be seen by someone is
is life-changing and so i think it's
it's going to be very moving hopefully
this is such an important exciting thing
to come up for all of our futures near
futures
um it's design week here at the show and
um
we were so curious as to what spoke to
you
on a design level this is one cool thing
with ben platt
[Music]
i i will share with you this one piece
that i really love
my boyfriend noah galvin's best friend
is a really talented artist
uh her name is mai ohana she's on
instagram it's mai
ohana and she makes beautiful uh like
woven pieces and rugs and she made me
this from my wall
and it's super pretty little kind of
rough coe moment um that
really brightens up the space and my
favorite color is blue and i wanted to
get some blue in here
and so if you need a piece like that you
need to check out her instagram
i love that piece so much i that is
more than i was expecting for one cool
thing
oh i do what i can um no you're such an
incredible musician multi-hyphenate by
the way only an oscar away from an egot
and
i'm pretty sure that's on the horizon in
the near near future
um what did you think of our wonderful
senior
friends uh i mean i was
i was grooving and i think that i'm
going to be quite distracted
um when i'm doing my peloton workouts
from now on would it be okay
to use our balls as percussion
instruments
i'm not sure that would work you want to
drum our way out
into the commercial break together ben
because when we come back
we're inviting your sister for a really
meaningful conversation that i have been
so excited you know um maybe you
actually can take us out of this you
guys ready
all right
[Music]
you